John B. Watson famously claimed that if he
were to be given a dozen healthy infants
he could shape them into anything:
doctors, lawyers, artists, beggars or
thieves, regardless of their background
or genetic predispositions. First he
completed experiments with eight-month
old Albert and later he applied his
theory when raising his own children. In
essence he applied the scientific method
to human psychology which he called
behaviorism. With the little Albert
experiment
Watson used the method of classical
conditioning to program a baby to be
afraid of a lab rat. Earlier Pavlov
demonstrated how conditioning can
trigger biological responses that are
inherited genetically. Watson
hypothesized that we can also instill
new behaviors that were not inherited. To
conduct the experiment Watson and his
assistant Rosalie Rayner placed the boy
in a room where a white rat was allowed
to roam around. First, the boy showed no
fear.
Then Rayner struck a steel bar with a
hammer every time Albert reached out to
touch the rat, scaring Albert and causing
him to cry. Eventually, Albert tried to
get away from the rat showing that he
had been conditioned to fear the rat.
Weeks later Albert showed distress
towards any furry object showing that
his conditioning had not only been
sustained but also generalized. Watson
assumed that our behavior is either a
reflex evoked by a stimulus or a
consequence of our individual history of
earlier exposure to reinforcements and
punishments paired with our current
motivational states and stimuli.
Unlike Freud and Jung he was not
interested in thoughts or the mind
because in his opinion the analysis of
actions and reactions were the only way
to apply the scientific method to
psychology and get objective insights
into human behavior.
He thought of psychology as an objective
branch of Natural Science, its goal the
prediction and control of behavior. Like
his fellow behaviorists he believed that
intelligence, temperament, and personality
are determined by the environment in
which the child is raised. Watson
published "the psychological care of
infant and child". In his book he advised
parents not to touch their children too
often and to keep an emotional distance so
as not to spoil them. Playing with
children, he warned, would interrupt their
routines. A happy child doesn't cry or
seek attention. His book became a
best-seller and soon other scientists of
his time advised against showing
affection. Some Western governments
started to hand out leaflets advising
that parents should stop kissing their
children. Parents developed the idea that
children should be left to sit quietly
during the day at night, they should be
left crying alone until they fall asleep.
A method called sleep training. Watson
who had a difficult childhood wanted to
be a good father and applied his methods
to his four children John, Mary, James, and
William. Unfortunately things didn't turn
out as planned: John complained
throughout his entire life about
intolerable headaches and died early in
his 50s. Mary developed a drinking
problem and attempted suicide, like her
brother James. William took his own life
at age 40. Watson allegedly admitted that
he regretted writing about child-rearing
as he realized he didn't know enough
about it to do so. Towards the end of his
life he became reclusive and prior to
his death in 1958
he burned all of his recent papers. What
do you think? Watson was convinced that
the kind of nurturing we receive can
determine our life path claiming that he
could turn an infant into any man he
wishes, in his own family though
depression and bad habits were passed on
from generation to generation. Does this
happen due to genetic predispositions or
is it the effect of a child's
unfortunate upbringing?
Sprouts videos are published under the
Creative Commons license that means our
videos are free and anyone can download,
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools governments and nonprofit
organizations can also use them for
training, online courses, or designing new
curriculums.
If you want to help us reach more
students you can subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell button, or share
this video with a friend! to help us stay
independent and support our work you can
join our patrons and contribute! Just
visit www.patreon.com/sprouts. Even one
dollar can make a difference! If you have
deep insights into academic topics and
want to help us explain complicated
ideas in simple language, please contact
us at sproutsschools.com.